if you have a goal and you're struggling
to find the courage to keep going I'm
going to share with you today my simple
trick that keeps me motivated so got a
great question for one of my YouTube
viewers love you guys I'm God who wrote
in this a great work
thanks I'm God could you create a video
about how to be committed to your goal
because you start perfectly but after
while your courage is going down once
this happens giving up becomes a result
moreover you might get into a bad
psychological mood as well my greetings
I'm God this is such a super important
question because if you have the
audacity if you have the boldness to
step outside your comfort zone and try
to launch a business or try to reach for
this crazy goal the only way to keep it
going is to change your environment you
see you have an environment that holds
you where you are we all do and if you
want to increase the standard of living
for yourself you want to increase the
quality of your life you want to
increase the quality of your goals that
can't happen without an equal increase
in the quality of your environment too
many people get so unhappy with their
lives that they then say I want to
change it I want to reach for this new
goal I want to start this new business
but they don't change their environments
and so they ultimately fail so my simple
trick to keep myself motivated is I
change my environment let's start
thinking about your environment think
about the books that you read if you
read any think about the shows that you
watch the movies that you watch the
music that you listen to think about
your daily routine
think about the office space that you
work in think about what's on the wall
think about who your mentors are think
about who you look up to and now the
tough one think about who your friends
are
think about who your family is how many
of the things and the people in your
environment hold you where you are
versus encourage you to become better
here's what happens to a lot of people
we get a spark of inspiration
maybe you stumble onto a YouTube video
and that ignite some passion in
maybe you go to some seminar you hear
this great speaker and that ignites some
passion in you maybe you read a book or
you listen to a song and you think man I
want to go out and accomplish something
big with my life and you have that
moment of boldness where you're willing
to step outside your comfort zone and go
chase your dreams sometimes that
boldness expires overnight and the next
day you're starting up from scratch
sometimes that boldness might last you a
week or a month or a couple months but
more often than not that boldness will
expire because all that was was a spark
and you've got no base you've got no
wood to build an amazing fire so you
have to change your environment to match
that spark whatever that new goal of
yours is that makes you push beyond your
comfort zone you have to think how can I
match everything in my environment now
to support the achievement of that goal
how am I going to change the websites
that I visit and the books that I read
in the TV shows that I watch what new
music am I going to begin listening to
what new movies am I going to start
watching who are the kinds of people
that I need to start surrounding myself
with and who are the people who I need
to cut out or cut back from in my life
you need to take a hard deep honest look
at yourself and your environment because
chances are you've done this as a
pattern you had a great idea and it
fizzled out and another great idea and
it fizzled out and another great idea
and it fizzled out you kept coming up
with great ideas but you never change
your environment to match it so that's
my simple trick to staying motivated I
change my environment to match my dreams
it's simple but it's not easy and if you
can do it it'll change your life believe
thank you for the great question if you
guys like this video you want to see
more like it you can subscribe to the
channel thank you so much for watching
I'll see you soon south improvement
books are like Fitness books they never
work on their own what you need is a
trainer that's Evan get the newsletter
you